going back to what you said about Brian
here he has this amazing story he's you
know done his homework he's given it to
other people he crashed the party to
meet you or just to be around people
that he knew would be the right people
to get it to but then you said there was
a part of him that maybe people didn't
believe in and and having had the same
thing sort of said about myself being
too nervous sometimes I think it's hyper
awareness so how does somebody who maybe
isn't that social network or who just
doesn't walk into a room and whose
confidence how do they how do they do
that how do they can't over come that or
do they give it to someone like yourself
who is a people person who does who
knows how to kind of just be sort of in
the moment and well I was given the
advice by my party crashing friend early
on he said the worst thing that can
happen is that they'll say no so if
that's the worst that can happen go for
it
seriously in the longest sense of like
yeah as opposed to it takes so much more
energy yeah your ego might get bruised a
little bit but the outcome could be
amazing and there have been those you
know situations where I've gone ahead
and been confident I think there was one
time I was auditioning for a commercial
and I was literally like an hour and 30
minutes away from the audition during
traffic hour and I just wasn't going to
make it in time but I raced over there
and I got there like five minutes after
they shut it down I walked in and
they're like sorry we're closed and I
walked out of the building and you know
you start to feel down you're upset that
you know a you were in traffic and if
you've been in traffic in Los Angeles
instantly you know how that makes you
feel and but I was becoming more
frustrated at the fact that i just took
no for an answer
you know so I went back and I said
listen I've been driving for an hour and
a half in LA traffic just to make this
audition I'm not late intentionally it's
you know circumstantial so please see me
and they did and I booked the job
sometimes you just have to push all that
stuff aside because the worst thing that
he could have said was no he could have
said no I said no once I'll say it again
that's fine but you know it's that kind
of taking that initiative and and making
it happen and I've been in situations
where you you know and I have really
famous friends now and you do always
feel like all I shouldn't ask them that
but I don't give a rat's ass I'll ask
them and the worst they can say is no
and if they hate me for just asking
that's on them you know because the
thing is you you need to do what you
need to do as long as you're not
disrespectful and mean you know
obnoxious and accept that accept the
fact that someone said no and respect
that and move on move on to the next
door there's always another door as well
so I think taking that and that's what
we did with Mission Park is that we went
to these meetings you know because we
believed in the project we believed in
ourselves and we got so many no's like
no change your characters too white you
know your director stutters he's not
confident enough all these things that
had nothing to do with the actual
project and like I said Armando
Montelongo was above all that and he saw
the project for what it was and believed
in it and that's what we believe we
believe that we would find someone who
saw what we saw we did and then in the
theatrical stages we spent an entire
year hearing no from every single studio
in this city every distributor no no no
we love the film looks beautiful we just
can't market a film with all Latino
casts and most of them are unknown yet
and we just kept pushing with like no
this film is going to get at the article
distribution it's going to get it and
David Jay Phillips my co-producer he's
been in the business for a while and he
had some really great relationships and
one of them was with AMC theaters and he
gave them mission park they loved it and
their perception is different from
hollywood's because they're more like
the netflix of theater chains you know
they they know who is going into their
theaters they have that data so when
they see films they see it from that
perspective as like wow this is a type
of film that our audience would like
that people would come to see and I
think Netflix is the same and their
approach is different and there's a
whole new wave of doing things now
and Mission Park is sort of in the
forefront of that
you